hi guys scifi recapped here
before we start warning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2018 german adventure and science
fiction movie called invisible sue
the movie begins with sue short for
suzanne daydreaming about her favorite
superhero character in a comic book
super moon
she snaps back into reality and realizes
the class has been emptied then makes
her way out
she regards herself as being invisible
in school as she is always ignored by
the popular kids she is picked up by her
dad christoph who plans to take her to
her mother's lab to give her a birthday
surprise
she wants to prove to her mother that
she is not invisible to her too although
her mother maria is too deeply involved
in her work that she seldom cares about
her own daughter
maria is about to give a speech at a
scientific event hosted by dr drill
while sue and christoph prepare for her
birthday surprise at her lap
unfortunately the birthday candle
kristoff lit sets off the fire alarm
causing maria and her team to check on
it she is furious knowing sue and
kristoff ruined her important day
sue is really disappointed as her effort
to catch her mother's attention turns
out to be a failure thus she throws the
birthday cake out of anger the cake hits
a machine then causes instability in the
lab
su panics and tries to push random
buttons to make everything go back to
normal but the temperature instability
only gets worse
she hears a robotic voice but does not
really care what it says
she goes to check on the reactor but it
is too unstable that the lab activates a
lockdown mechanism so she is trapped
inside then an explosion happens
fortunately sue survives with just minor
injuries and she goes home with her
father
on the way home she notices a blue glow
emitting from her wound but does not say
anything
the next morning sue wakes up to her
left limb disappearing causing her to
vomit out of shock
she goes to the school as usual parting
with kristoff who will be working abroad
for some time and is checking her locker
when a nice guy approaches her his name
is tobias and he is also interested in
super moon comics but they are
interrupted by eileen and her friends
sue's bullies when eileen is talking to
tobias sue disappears again and heads to
the restroom
she washes her hands and scares a girl
who thinks the restroom is haunted
slowly she starts reappearing again
after cooling her hands with running
water
still puzzled by her current condition
she goes to her mother at the lab
maria is surprised and aims to run tests
on her but sue dismisses her saying how
ignorant her mother can be when her
daughter is only seen as a scientific
experiment she knows that her
breakthrough experiment aimed to provide
ultimate health for humans called nt26d
is infused with sue's blood during the
explosion and develops her ability to
become invisible
the ability is only triggered by hot
temperatures and only lasts as long as
sue is exposed to warm surfaces
she advises sue to stay at home until
she can figure out something to do with
her but sue refuses and leaves for
school
at school she meets tobias again who
awkwardly asks her to go hang out
somewhere however eileen and her gang
interrupt them again saying to tobias
that he is too cool to hang out with sue
eileen then receives a call with a very
weird ringtone she runs out of
embarrassment turns out the prank is
caused by kaia also called app a weird
robotic club girl at the school
after school sue sits at her mom's lab
while maria and lenia another scientist
conduct experiments on her condition
they discover that everything sue
touches also disappears when she is
disappearing as demonstrated by sue
touching lenia when becoming invisible
lenia feels powerful and that inspires
her
maria grows terrified of the condition
that her daughter's condition can be
unsafe or that her experiment can be
used for evil purposes so she plans to
delete the experiments
sue is against that and she leaves with
disappointment she goes to the school's
basement and takes a nap there and is
surprised to see that app can see her
sue grows really tired and can quickly
fall asleep as she is exhausted from
keeping herself invisible
they eat at the nearby diner and sue is
trying to tell app of her weird
condition when eileen enters the room
and is about to make fun of them again
sue sees that opportunity to demonstrate
her invisibility and attacks eileen
instead which surprises app
meanwhile dr drill sees the footage of
maria and lenia examining invisible sue
at the lab when maria and sue arrive
home maria is about to pick sleepy sue
up when she is kidnapped by unknown men
sue is still groggy when she hears her
mother screaming and instructing her to
find alfred in the red mask
now aware of her surroundings sue
quickly turns herself invisible so the
men cannot find her she calls kristoff
but he is busy then quickly gets out of
her house
she meets toby showing off his bicycle
skills and asks him to help her he
encourages her to be brave despite her
weird abilities just like the super moon
character the following morning sue
accompanied by toby goes back to her
mother's car to retrieve her laptop that
might help her find more information
about alfred and her mother's captors
she receives a mysterious call telling
her to get in the car's trunk as fast as
possible
although hesitant she and toby follow
the instruction then they hear dr
drill's men's voices searching the room
and driving the car somewhere when the
trunk is open from the outside they
discover it is app defeating the guards
with her tech abilities
sue tells them that dr drill may hold
her mother hostage and that she needs to
get into his facility to save her
she takes toby with her making both of
them invisible they do not find maria
but toby retrieves a cell phone left on
the floor which seems to belong to maria
dr drill and his man almost catch them
but luckily they escape
app takes them to her quirky aunt's
house at lore who demands to see sue in
private turns out she recognizes maria
as they were once partners and she
already warned her about the danger of
her experiment but she would not listen
app examines videos from maria's phone
to find she recorded herself running and
getting attacked then the phone fell off
until toby found it alfred turns out to
be an ai device who is maria's assistant
found inside maria's bag through
alfred's holographic projection they
discover that the nt-26d cannot react to
anyone except sue's blood and that maria
has tried to find an antidote but fails
they deduce that dr drill is actually
after sue not her mother because sue
holds the key to nt 26d's success
to keep her safe sue switched beds with
toby so that her captors would be fooled
they almost catch toby but then realizes
it is not sue and quickly leave leaving
behind a syringe which toby finds when
he wakes up in the morning app presents
a new suit for invisible sue which can
help sue control her abilities and stay
awake
sue then receives a call from maria
seemingly escaping from an abandoned
facility and tells her to meet in the
old market by the fountain in an hour
in the market the three children sent
something is not quite right when they
find that doctor drills men approach
them
they deduce that they have been lured
into a trap and escape by stealing a
pizza delivery bike
unbeknownst to them lenia follows them
in a car
they follow alfred's signal to maria's
last known location in an abandoned
factory
however toby is not sure of their plan
and becomes hesitant to continue he
argues with sue with sue mocking him for
being afraid and that he will be better
off at the halloween party with eileen
and the gang
disappointed toby leaves
app and sue are then cornered by
surveillance drones so they hide
somewhere until nightfall
then they plan to escape by distracting
drill and as men by throwing an nt26d
that will explode after the explosion
sue falls unconscious and wakes up next
to his mother reading her comic book
she asks her how her friends are doing
to which she replies that app is still
at the abandoned factory waiting for her
while toby is at the halloween party her
mother leaves but then sue realizes she
is locked up in her own room and cannot
escape even through the window
turns out her mother is lenia in
disguise who injects herself with sue's
blood when she is still unconscious to
obtain her own superpowers shown by
alfred's footage which sue later learns
from
meanwhile the real maria picks up app
from the abandoned factory then
retrieves her daughter although sue is
hesitant maria proves she is real by
activating alfred as only members of the
hartman family can activate the ai they
then go to the halloween party to rescue
toby as they know lenia is after him to
erase witnesses
along the way maria gives sue the
antidote for her invisibility as she
promised but sue is now hesitant to use
it if she thinks she does not need to be
cured although maria does not ask too
sue plans to inject the antidote into
lenia to defeat her at the party eileen
is dancing with toby but then goes to
get more drinks and scolds one of her
friends an unlikely behavior
sue deduces that lenia disguises herself
as eileen and the real eileen is hidden
somewhere she orders app to produce fog
effects to confuse lenia so she can
bring toby to safety
she then injects lenia with the antidote
after offering toby her apology the
three bring unconscious lenia to the
rooftop where they are surprisingly met
by ant lore
turns out she is the real mastermind
behind it all wanting the nt26d inside
sue's veins for herself
she is the one who lenia works for and
also orders the men to kidnap sue's
parents sue takes a brave step by
injecting herself with the antidote so
nt 26d will be useless and aunt lore
cannot use it then plants one of app's
devices in ant-lord's wheelchair causing
it to move and spin uncontrollably as
antler is defeated sue embraces her
family and friends before falling asleep
due to heavy exhaustion
she wakes up next to her parents and is
being well taken care of in app's
luxurious mansion
sue app and toby then realize the
antidote may not be very effective and
continue their adventure by being
invisible together
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching